how's it going everybody it's Warren and
ever since Avengers endgame has come out
everybody has been wondering what is
going to happen in phase four there's a
lot that is set up to happen in phase
four but one of the most exciting things
that is going to be coming is Adam
warlock this was set up a long time ago
in the post credit scene of guardians of
the galaxy volume 2 so we've known that
this is going to be coming for some time
now and it seems like in phase 4 we're
finally going to see it happen and
Avengers endgame has actually set it up
perfectly for Adam warlock to come and
guardians of the galaxy volume 3 and
I'll bring it all down in this video but
first a quick reminder if you're new to
my channel be sure to subscribe to stay
up to date on everything related to
Marvel and all things superhero so like
I said in the post credits scene of
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 they
actually set up Adam warlock to come in
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and in
fact there was a lot of talk about Adam
warlock appearing in Avengers infinity
war and Avengers in game but Marvel shut
it down saying that Adam warlock is not
coming until 2020 when we see guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 now obviously with
the firing and the rehiring of James
Gunn guardians of the galaxy vol 3 got
pushed back to 2022 but it is confirmed
that it is happening James Gunn is
directing it and there is even a script
for it already developed so it's
definitely coming in 2022 and Avengers
in game actually set it up perfectly
also if you haven't seen Avengers in
game I'm about to jump into some
spoilers so in Avengers in game they
brought back Gamora it's not the same
Gamora that died she is permanently dead
but they did bring back 2014 Gamora this
is so she can be in guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 there's no doubt that some
of the story probably the beginning is
going to be finding Gamora and
reintroducing her to the guardians of
the galaxy remember at the end of
Infinity Ward nebula was on the ship
with the Guardians so there's no doubt
that she's going to want to track down
her sister Gamora and that star-lord is
going to want to track down Gamora too
because he's in love with her whether
it's the pass Gamora or not so that's
going to be part of the story but
remember the Guardians also have Thor
with them now and the reason that the
Guardians have Thor with them now is for
one simple reason the guardians of the
galaxy that exist
the MCU right now are not strong enough
to take on Adam warlock
especially since star-lord doesn't have
his celestial powers I actually think
that he does still have them he just
doesn't know how to tap into them and
that's something that we'll see maybe at
the end of guardians of the galaxy vol 3
when they fight against Adam warlock but
remember in the post-credits scene the
sovereign actually made Adam warlock to
go and kill the guardians of the galaxy
so Adam warlock is going to be going
against the Guardians trying to kill
them in the movie and given how strong
Adam warlock is in the comics there's no
way that the Guardians could take him on
however they now have Thor Thor with
Stormbreaker
and that's a good fight for with the
guardians of the galaxy against Adam
warlock now the guardians of the galaxy
have a chance to defeat him and I'm sure
that by the end of the movie Adam
warlock is going to be a good guy but
for the majority of the movie he's going
to be evil and tried to kill the
guardians of the galaxy Thor being with
the guardians of the galaxy to take on
Adam warlock is why we didn't see Adam
warlock in Avengers infinity war or
Avengers endgame again in the MCU Adam
is designed to kill the guardians of the
galaxy not be a hero and he would
completely destroy the Guardians
especially since star-lord doesn't have
his celestial powers so they needed to
wait until Thor joined the Guardians
which couldn't happen until after
Avengers in game and they set it up
perfectly at the end of Avengers in game
Thor on the Benatar with the Guardians
and judging by what we saw Thor is going
to fit right in with a Guardians humor
so Adam warlock is coming in phase 4 in
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and not
only will he be taking on the guardians
but he will also be taking on Thor which
is something that I think is going to be
completely amazing to see in a movie but
let me know your thoughts on this let me
know how excited you are to see the
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 introduced
Adam warlock and Adam go against Thor
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below and again if you're
new to my channel be sure to subscribe
so you can stay up to date on everything
relating to Marvel and all things
superhero as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby now
you're it